وينضم الان الينا من مستشفى ناصر في خان
يونس مراسلنا مؤمن شرافي اهلا مؤمن اذا
وسط هذا القصف الكثيف لخان يونس كيف يمكن
وصف الاوضاع
تفضل نعم ليلى الاوضاع هي ماساويه وصعبه
للغايه وكارثه في مختلف المناطق في مدينه
خان يونس قوات الاحتلال كثفت في محيط مجمع
ناصر لدينا
من اطلاق القنابل الدخانيه لعلكم تشاهدون
حتى اعمده الدخان يصل من هذه القنابل الى
داخل الساحه التي نقف بها في مجمع ناصر
الطبي الى جانب قصف مدفعي وسماع اطلاقات
ناريه كثيفه في المحور الجنوبي الذي تتجه
اليه عدسه الكرا المنطقه الجنوبيه من مجمع
ناصر تسمعون ذوي الانفجارات هذه
الانفجارات لا
تتوقف على الاطلاق منذ مساء يوم امس وحتى
هذه اللحظه الى جانب الاطلاقات الناريه
الان تقوم قوات الاحتلال باطلاق قنابل
دخانيه في اجواء المنطقه المحيطه بمجمع
ناصر الطبي وهذا المحور الذي تتجه اليه
عدسه الكاميرا هو المحور الذي يشهد
اشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال التي توغلت من خلاله الى المنطقه
الغربيه من خانيونس
وقطعت الطرق الواصله بين مدينتي خانيونس
ورفح وبالتالي من بقي داخل خانيونس سواء
من من الاطباء من طواقم الاسعاف من
الصحفيين هم باتوا محاصرين لا يستطيعون
الوصول الى ترين الان تشاهدين هذا طفل طفل
شهيد يحمله والده على
ال يحاول ان يدفنه في اي مكان المقبره
تتواجد فيها الاليات العسكريه والدبابات
الاسرائيليه لا اعرف الى اين يتجه بطفله
الصغير
الشهيد الناس هنا اضطروا داخل مجمع ناصر
الى دفن الشهداء داخل اسوار المجمع نتيجه
الحصار الذي تفرضه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على المقبره وعدم تمكن
المواطنين وذوي واهالي الشهداء من الوصول
الى المقبره لدفن
الى تاسس مقبره جماعيه دا مجمع ناصر امام
العدد الكبير من الشهداء نتحدث عن 30
شهيدا حتى هذه اللحظه من تمكنوا المواطنون
من انتشالهم والوصول بهم الى مستشفى ناصر
الى جانب العشرات من الجرحى جل الشهداء
والجرحى وجل الصور التي نشاهدها وما
نشاهدها في قسم الاستقبال والط هم من
اطفال والنساء كما تشاهد على عدسه
الكاميرا هذا الطفل يحاول والده ان يكفنه
بقطعه قماش بسيطه جدا بما توفر لديه لنقل
هي عربه على عربه على عربه يجرها حمار
حيوان ياتي المصابون ياتي الجرحى لا توجد
سيارات اسعاف وضع كارثي جدا ليى هنا في
مدينه خانيونس لا توجد سيارات اسعاف
تستطيع الوصول الى مناطق تشهد اشتباكات
تشهد قصف مدفعي الاسرائيلي عبر
عربات ياتي الجرحى
والشهداء
وايضا الوضع اقل ما يمكن ان نوصفه هنا في
مدينه خان يونس هو وضع ماساوي وصعب جدا لا
كوادر طبيه كافيه شاهدتم الصور قبل ان
اظهر على النشره الاطباء يضطرون الى علاج
الجرحى وانقاذ حياتهم على الارض لا توجد
اسره الكوا وادر الطبيه عددها محدود جدا
امام الاعداد الكبيره من
الجرحى الذين
يصلون الذين يصلون تباعا وعلى مدار الساعه
الى مستشفى ناصر
وايضا هذا حسب ما افدنا به ان هؤلاء
الشهداء والجرحى الذين وصلوا عبر هذه
العربه عربه النقل
البسيطه هم مدرسه تابعه الى
استهدفتها دبابات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذا الرجل متطوع يستخدم عربته البسيطه
وينقل منذ ساعات الصباح الاحظه ينقل
الشهداء والجرحى مختلف المناطق في مدينه
خانيونس واتي بهم الى هنا سيارات الاسعاف
لا تستطيع ان تتحرك مترا واحدا سواء خارج
مستشفى الامل او مقر جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
مركز الاسعاف او حتى من هنا من يتحر ر من
سيارات الاسعاف التابعه لوزاره الصحه من
الطواقم الطبيه يتحرك على عاطق الشخصي
لانتشال ما يمكن انتشاله من الشهداء وايضا
الوصول الى جرحى ومحاصرين نتحدث عن عائلات
محاصره داخل منازلها نتحدث عن نازحين
محاصرين داخل المدارس والجامعات التي
تحولت منذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه الطاحنه
على غزه الى مراكز ايواء هذا الرجل يبدو
انه لا يدري اين سيذهب بطفله اين سيدنه
بعد اي حصار واحتلال قوات ودبابات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للمقبره الوحيده
القريبه من مجمع ناصر الطبي والتي كان
يدفن فيها جميع الشهداء ويبدو انه سيضطر
الى ان يواري طفله الثرى في المقبره
الجماعيه التي تم تاسيسها قبل قليل داخل
اسوار ناصر بجانب المشرحه لمباراته الثرى
داخل اسوار مجمع ناصر الطبي الوضع صعب جدا
ليلى هنا في مدينه خانيونس على الصعيد
الانساني على الصعيد الصحي على الصعيد
الحياتي فما بالك
بعد قطع جميع الطرق الواصله بين مدينه خان
يونس والمدن الاخرى كمدينه رفح في الجنوب
ومدينه ديرب بلح في
الشمال قدر ابل من الكلام هنا في مدينه
نعم كلمه صعب هذه يعني اقل ما
يقال نشاهد معك ال وبفعل هذا المشهد للاب
الذي فقد ابنه ويكفي الالم الذي عاناه
ولكنه ايضا يبحث عن مكان لدفنه والكل
يتجمهر حوله